After Natalie Portman was revealed at Comic-Con
2019 to be taking the mantle of Thor in the
upcoming Thor: Love and Thunder, artists began
imagining what she would look like when she
transforms into the Goddess of Thunder.
Here are what a few fans thought the actress
could look like as the Mighty Thor.
Artist Pablo Ruiz, who goes by the handle
@pabloruizzx on Instagram, envisioned Natalie
Portman's Mighty Thor as a companion to Chris
Hemsworth's Asgardian God of Thunder.
Holding the mystical hammer Mjolnir in her
hand, with her eyes glowing blue, Jane-as-Thor
stands behind the Odinson as he reaches back
for her help.
It appears that @pabloruizzx used a Jane Foster
Sideshow Collectibles figure designed by Ian
MacDonald and Alex Pascenko as the basis for
this edit.
Popular Australian artist Mizuri, who goes
by @mizuriofficial on Instagram, quickly shared
their vision of the Mighty Thor.
In their artwork, Natalie Portman's Jane Foster
wears armor, a dark red cape, and a helmet
evocative of the Jane Foster Thor from the
comics.
Mizuri also posted an unmasked version of
the Jane Foster Thor edit, which uses a Thor:
The Dark World poster featuring Portman as
a starting point for these creative alterations.
Artist @doubledomino made a piece featuring
the Mighty Thor wearing her comic book headgear
surrounded by a storm of lightning.
Their artwork also uses the Thor: The Dark
World poster of Portman as a basis and uses
the Jane Foster Thor helmet design provided
by Do3D.com.
ALASTØR, a longtime comic book fan and art
director posting on Instagram under the username
@alastor_c, predicted years ago that Natalie
Portman would eventually become the next Thor
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
"You're--" "I'm Loki." * "That was for
New York."
"I like her!"
His idea for how the Jane Foster Thor could
look on screen?
She dons a red cape, wears a silver chest-plate,
and wields not one but two weapons — Mjolnir
and the Dwarven-forged battle axe Jarnbjorn.
It looks like @alastor_c used the Jane Foster
figure for a base and then Photoshopped Portman's
head in place of Jane's.
Indonesian artist @awedope.arts uploaded a
striking image depicting Jane Foster and Thor
Odinson standing side by side as if they're
about to partner up and take down a baddie
together.
While Odinson, his hair long and his beard
braided, holds his battle axe Stormbreaker
in both hands, a helmet-wearing Mighty Thor
carries Mjolnir.
Once again, it looks like the artwork makes
use of the Jane Foster figure as the basis
for the Mighty Thor.
Self-proclaimed "graphic wizard" Jakub Masłowski,
@jakubmaslowski_ on Instagram, imagined that
the Portman as Thor will sport a simpler look
in Thor: Love and Thunder, wearing the classic
costume fans saw in the first Thor film.
In Maslowski's artwork, Portman's Mighty Thor
wears the signature red cape, intricately
designed armor, and matching gauntlets originally
worn by Chris Hemsworth in Thor.
And, of course, she has the lightning-powered
Mjolnir in hand as well.
"Oh.
My.
God."
Natalie Portman's Mighty Thor could sport
an intense appearance in Thor: Love and Thunder,
if artist @ihasankazi's vision for the character
ends up being accurate.
In their artwork, the Mighty Thor has a heavier
costume and glowing blue eyes.
Instead of creating a Photoshop edit of what
Natalie Portman's Mighty Thor could look like
in Thor: Love and Thunder, artist Nikolay
Mochkin, @ellejart on Instagram, created a
complete illustration of the character.
Here, Jane Foster is depicted taking to the
skies, her red cape flowing behind her and
Mjolnir summoning the power of lightning up
above.
We'll just have to wait and see if Natalie
Portman's Mighty Thor looks like any of these
fantastic portrayals or instead ends up closer
to the look she had in the animated series
Avengers Assemble.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.